[Música]
Hola Yo soy Natalia Cabrera parada y
esto es aquí América el magacín de
France 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias y las historias de nuestro
continente y Estos son nuestros
titulares
más de 80 bloqueos dejan a regiones del
Perú sin alimentos ni combustible en ica
al sur de Lima de la capital el Hospital
Regional alerta que se queda sin oxígeno
para pacientes la situación es crítica y
las partes Siguen sin ceder
se celebró en Buenos Aires la séptima
cumbre de la comunidad de Estados
latinoamericanos y caribeños la celac
una cita marcada por una Nueva Ola de
gobierno de izquierda que finalizó con
una declaración de compromiso por mayor
integración entre estas naciones y en
Estados Unidos los archivos nacionales
pidieron a los expresidentes y ex
vicepresidentes revisar si tienen en su
poder documentos clasificados El llamado
llega después del hallazgo de registros
oficiales en posesión de Donald Trump
Joe biden y Michaels
y nos vamos de inmediato a Perú para
nuestra historia principal continúan las
manifestaciones los bloqueos y las
muertes la situación no mejora y los
ciudadanos siguen en las calles para
exigir elecciones anticipadas y la
renuncia de Dina boluarte quien asumió
el poder tras la destitución de Pedro
Castillo quien fue depuesto por el
congreso por rebelión luego de que el
Entonces mandatario intentara disolver
el legislativo que iba a reunirse a
debatir una moción de vacancia en su
contra por señalamientos de corrupción
también piden elecciones anticipadas
boluartes se niega a dimitir mientras el
congreso propuso una moción de vacancia
ahora en contra de ella con miras a
removerla del cargo un congreso en el
que los peruanos tampoco confían la
crisis entró en un punto de inflexión y
en medio de la inestabilidad los jefes
de estado y de gobierno de la región
comienzan a dividir sus apoyos veamos el
informe que nos preparó al respecto de
Luis Muñoz
Perú cada vez más solo en un mapa
latinoamericano dominado por la
izquierda la presión exterior crece
contra el gobierno de Dina boluarte el
cual trata de resistir y responder el
último caso La retirada de su embajador
en Honduras el gobierno ha retirado
definitivamente al embajador de Perú en
Honduras en respuesta a la inaceptable
en gerencia en asuntos internos de la
presidenta Xiomara Castro en su
intervención en la celac desconociendo
al gobierno constitucional de la
presidenta Dina boluarte
el canciller de Honduras Enrique reina
mantuvo la postura de la presidenta
Xiomara Castro pidió la liberación de
Pedro castillo y calificó de golpe de
estado lo sucedido en Perú no se deben
permitir más golpes de estado en América
Latina bajo ninguna forma Esperamos que
el pueblo peruano restituya la legalidad
en pleno respeto y garantías de sus
derechos humanos en un proceso
democrático y limpio semanas atrás Perú
había pedido la salida del país del
embajador de México a quien también
declaró persona no ingrata las
relaciones entre ambos estados siguen
siendo críticas y el presidente mexicano
Andrés Manuel López Obrador incluso fue
más allá es lo de la ONU de la oea
dónde estaban
Ya basta
de estar simulando
de estar este actuando de manera
falsaria
ya no queremos farsa otro país con el
que Perú mantiene un pulso es con su
vecina Bolivia su gobierno niega
acusaciones de envío de armas y
municiones mientras el congreso peruano
declaró no un grato al expresidente
boliviano Evo Morales al mismo se le
había negado la entrada al país a
principios de mes la superintendencia ha
decidido decretar el impedimento de
ingreso al Perú del señor Evo Morales y
de varios de sus partidarios por afectar
directamente las normas de Perú pulso
del Primer Ministro peruano Alberto
tarola quien también mantuvo roces con
el presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro
así había tuiteado este último allanar
universidades gritar muera la
inteligencia el consejo permanente de la
oea debe ser citado para examinar el
caso de Perú y así le respondió tarola
ocúpese sus asuntos señor Gustavo Petro
consejo permanente oea también podría
examinar ocurridas durante su gobierno
la última en el putumayo gobierne para
los suyos asista A las víctimas mejores
sus universidades otros países de
izquierda de la región también tuvieron
palabras sobre la situación peruana
durante la última cumbre de la comunidad
de Estados latinoamericanos y caribeños
Perú se quejó de estas palabras del
presidente de Chile Gabriel boric
por eso también
en nuestra hermana República del Perú
con el gobierno bajo el mando de Dina
boluarte personas que salen a marchar a
reclamar lo que consideran justo
terminan baleadas por quien debiera
defenderlas de forma similar también
había hablado el cancier de Argentina la
violación de Derechos Humanos que está
haciendo que que está llevándose
adelante en Perú con respecto a la
violencia institucional que hay en Perú
para Todo fue
un tema de relevancia
la crítica contra la violenta respuesta
a las protestas ha llegado a estamentos
internacionales como misiones de la oea
y la cidh el alto comisionado de la ONU
y hasta el Papa Francisco el conflicto
inició el 7 de diciembre cuando se
convoca una tercera vacancia contra el
expresidente Pedro Castillo con
señalamientos de corrupción este
disolvió el congreso y tras ser
destituido fue detenido iniciando una
crisis política para la que todavía
queda lejos una solución
y precisamente como lo veíamos en el
informe la crisis en Perú se tomó las
discusiones de la Cumbre de la celac que
tuvo lugar en Buenos Aires y este tema
dejó en evidencia los discursos
contradictorios de los mandatarios Pues
mientras en la declaración final
apoyaron la no intervención extranjera
en asuntos internos En referencia a
Venezuela varios de ellos como Petro de
Colombia y borich de chile hablaron
respecto a la situación peruana la cita
estuvo marcada por una Nueva Ola de
gobierno de izquierda nuestros
corresponsales de Colombia Honduras y
Brasil fueron a buscar historias que
muestran Hacia dónde se dirigen las
políticas en la región el narcotráfico
cierto es un actor del conflicto que más
Gilberto da una clase de memoria
histórica temario que ha llegado de
forma pionera a las escuelas de la
alcaldía de Bogotá la historia de muchos
de estos estudiantes también está
marcada por el conflicto
[Música]
Este es un mural sobre el conflicto
elaborado por los alumnos del colegio
Delia Zapata se hizo en 2022 con motivo
de la publicación del informe de la
comisión de la verdad que rinde cuenta
de las dinámicas del conflicto durante
cinco décadas el gobierno de Gustavo
Petro y Francia Márquez ha prometido
implementarlo en su sistema educativo es
el primer ejecutivo de izquierda en la
historia de Colombia y el primero de
este tipo en representar al país en la
celac un giro que llega hasta el estudio
de la propia historia entonces
enseñarles a ellos es construir un
futuro de cambio y de paz
después de 13 años en 2022 también hubo
cambio en Honduras con la proclamación
de Xiomara Castro como presidenta por lo
que la celac volverá a contar con la
presencia de un gobierno de izquierda en
Centroamérica una de sus principales
apuestas ha sido desde el deporte
remodelando decenas de instalaciones el
objetivo es reinsertar a niños y jóvenes
en riesgo por consumo de drogas
vinculación con maras y con el fin de
frenar la migración un ejemplo esa
bielsa gastumé que practica Kendo karate
muchos jóvenes se ha notado que han
hecho la diferencia han marcado una
diferencia saliendo mucho de alguna
adicción del alcohol de las drogas
Erika Hilton es una de las dos primeras
diputadas trans en la historia de Brasil
el país donde más personas de este
colectivo son asesinadas en el mundo
según datos de la ONU tras la ausencia
en la última celac del gobierno de Jair
bolsonaro Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
devuelve Brasil a la Cumbre y las
esperanzas a las diversidades
estamos reconstruyendo la narrativa de
la
sociedad de avance
Pero antes del gobierno Erika Hilton por
el rechazo familiar tuvo que vivir en la
calle a los 15 años 6 años después
retomó los estudios y se incorporó al
movimiento estudiantil hoy desde la
cámara seguirá su lucha en un Brasil que
igual que gran parte de América Latina
ha girado a la izquierda
y vamos a revisar la imagen de la semana
que nos la deja Lula que tras la Cumbre
de la celac se fue a Uruguay de visita
allí fue a visitar el expresidente Pepe
Mujica quien lo llevó a dar un paseo en
su icónico escarabajo donde los
políticos sudamericanos más influyentes
de las últimas décadas Y también vamos a
revisar la cifra de la semana 1 pues es
el primer año de gobierno de Xiomara
Castro en Honduras con grandes desafíos
por delante en materia de Derechos
Humanos como le advirtió en una carta
abierta a la organización amnistía
internacional
y nos vamos a Estados Unidos porque la
oficina de archivos nacionales pidió a
los expresidentes y ex vicepresidentes
de las últimas seis administraciones
previas a las de Joe biden que revisen
sus registros personales para determinar
si cuentan con algún documento
clasificado la institución envió la
carta tras el escándalo que involucra al
expresidente Donald Trump su
vicepresidente Mike pence y el actual
jefe de estado el informe es de
Valentina Torres Sánchez
revisar sus registros personales en
busca de documentos presidenciales Esto
es lo que pidió la oficina de archivos
nacionales en una carta enviada a los
expresidentes y ex vicepresidentes desde
la administración de Ronald Reagan hasta
la de Donald Trump la responsabilidad de
cumplir con la ley de registros
presidenciales no disminuye tras el
final de un gobierno por lo tanto
solicitamos que lleve a cabo una
evaluación de cualquier material
conservado fuera de los archivos
nacionales y administración de
documentos la solicitud se presenta solo
días después de que los abogados del ex
vicepresidente Mike pence se informaran
del hallazgo de documentos en residencia
de Indiana asegurando que habrían
llegado ahí por error
el exfuncionario se sumó así al
escándalo de documentos clasificados en
el que también está envuelto el
presidente Joe biden con hallazgos en su
residencia de Wilmington en enero y en
su oficina privada en el pentviden
Center en noviembre pasado en estos dos
casos los archivos fueron encontrados
por abogados que notificaron a las
autoridades y los entregaron contrario
al caso del expresidente Donald Trump en
el que los documentos fueron encontrados
en medio de un allanamiento en su casa
de Mara lago en Florida
la preocupación es que alguien puede
acceder a ellos poniendo nuestros
secretos en riesgo la información
clasificada contiene material que debe
ser protegido por seguridad nacional
la solicitud de los archivos nacionales
incluye revisar tanto documentos
clasificados como no clasificados y
aplica las administraciones posteriores
a la de Jimmy Carter que fue el
signatario de la ley de registros
presidenciales la normativa Establece
que todos los registros presidenciales
se transfieren a custodia de los
archivos nacionales en cuanto el
presidente deja el cargo
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí América por favor envíenme sus
comentarios en redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en su pantalla en la
producción estuvieron Luis Muñoz y
giovannie agudelo pueden ver esta
emisión y las anteriores en France
24.com
[Música]